In case you've been hiding under a rock
or if you just don't have twitter,
bless your heart.
Kanye West made his return to the
platform and proceeded to crack the
Internet with seven dirty words,
which would've put even George Carlin to
shame.
Last Saturday.
Kanye tweeted,
I love the way candace owens thinks.
If you don't know candice.
Oh,
and she's a black conservative woman who
originally went under the Youtube
Moniker,
red pill,
black candace caught fire online around
the summer of 2017,
and my interview with her in which we
discussed her evolution from a lefty to
a conservative,
is one of the moments that really put
her on the map.
It was the first time that she had been
able to explain herself in her own words
in a long form conversational setting.
I don't want to rehash the whole thing
right now,
but candace is no stranger to
controversy and you may remember that
infamous debate that I had with candice
and Blair white late last year.
The whole thing was a debacle.
I make no bones about it,
but hashtag save.
Dave trended on twitter to who might've
complained 2018 has already been a huge
year for candice as she was hired as
communications director for turning
point USA,
the largest conservative college group
in America.
Since then,
she's been touring the country with
Charlie Kirk,
talking to young people,
particularly young black people as why
they should embrace the victim mentality
rather than the victim mentality.
This is included directly attacking the
black lives matter movement as well as
democratic policies,
which candice argues has decimated the
black family and the black community.
Just last week,
candice,
Charlie and I spoke at Berkeley to a
wild crowd.
I'm proud to say that we had agreements
and we had disagreements and even though
our styles are different,
no doubt,
candice certainly goes for the juggler
more than I do.
I always enjoyed doing events with her
and seeing her evolve politically.
Something I know a bit about myself.
She's learning as she goes and as she
said to me in our interview,
if I had swallowed the red pill,
then she had snorted it.
Beyond any of the politics though,
candice is a friend and our differences
don't define us.
They actually bring us together.
All right.
Back to Connie for a second.
Beyond the headlines,
I don't know a ton about him,
although I'm obviously aware enough to
recognize what a transcending cultural
figure he is.
Not only is he hugely successful in the
music world,
he has a hugely successful fashion line
and he's married to Kim Kardashians who
has her own empire.
You may not like the guy for whatever
reason,
but make no mistake.
He is an absolute mogul.
I may not like or even respect the
influence that celebrities have over
culture these days,
but Kanye is truly someone who can move
people's minds with what he raps or with
what he tweets.
This is exactly what happened with these
seven words.
Immediately after Connie's tweet in
supportive candice,
the Internet went ablaze twitter
moments.
Lead story was about Kanye support for
far right.
Candice Owens.
Candice was called Anti Gay and racist.
Something I'm still confused about as
she's had dinner here with me and my
husband at our home where her antiganey
has never seemed to leak out as racist.
There's nothing like a white lefty
telling a black person who doesn't think
as they demand that they do,
that the black person is the actual
racist against their own race.
Irony is truly dead.
Folks.
On Monday this week,
Kanye refused to back down despite
hysterics from the media.
He tweeted out a bunch of videos by
another form of Rubin report.
Guess bestselling author and Dober
creators,
Scott Adams.
In essence,
these videos were Scott talking about
what a free thinker Kanye is.
That's it.
Next thing you know,
the usual suspects like buzzfeed media
at the daily beast and others were
labeling Scott Adams as far right.
We've seen the script a million times
before with anyone who dare challenge
leftist Orthodoxy,
be it candice Scott Column,
Moriarity,
Jordan Peterson,
or even little old me when mainstream
media has moved so far left that this
wide collection of people are all
smeared with the same charges of far
right racism.
You know that the overton window hasn't
just shifted,
it's shattered.
The authors of these pieces aren't
journalists,
they're activists,
or as candace says,
they are a journalist there hitman.
To recap,
we have a new player in Kansas who is
fearlessly saying how she believes that
the Democrats have used the black
community for decades and that the
victimhood mentality of the left is the
root of this problem.
This by the way,
is similar to what plenty of other
conservatives have been saying for
years,
and yes,
this includes even black conservatives
like my former guests,
Larry elder and Thomas Soul.
The voices of black conservatives and
others espousing similar ideas has been
largely ignored by the mainstream media.
However,
and that is exactly why everyone is
freaking out about his tweets.
He just gave oxygen to a set of ideas
that the Democrats and the mainstream
media don't want you to hear,
and since they've controlled the
narrative for so long,
they've relied on the usual smears of
racism,
homophobia,
and bigotry.
Instead of strengthening their own
ideas.
Your ideas get fat and lazy when you
don't have to work them out because
you've owned the narrative for so long.
This is where the modern left finds
itself right now.
If Kansas,
his views are far right,
then that means that about 40 percent of
America,
if not more,
falls into that category.
I do want to address a different lurking
danger here.
However,
I know candace and I believe her to be
forthright and passionate as she figures
this all out.
I obviously don't know Kanye nor any of
his political beliefs,
so we have an interesting match here
where candice is now the rocket and
Kanye is the jet fuel.
If candice doesn't do the intellectual
work to really figure out what she
believes and why she believes it all the
while being under the insane microscope
of the media that's going to be praying
for her to fail,
well then the rocket will be faulty and
this experiment will blow up.
What if Kanye says something absolutely
crazy tomorrow,
which is not only possible,
it's probable or something that's
counter to everything else that can just
believes he's been known to stir the
pot,
and I can only assume that something
like that will happen either
intentionally or by mistake.
Does her rocket ship run out of fuel in
midflight?
Where does that leave this incredible
momentum over the past year when I've
talked to people like Eric and Bret
Weinstein,
Jordan Peterson,
Ben Shapiro,
Larry Elder,
Thomas Soul,
and many others.
What I'm most impressed by is how
complete their outlook on politics and
more broadly on life is they don't jump
from conclusion to conclusion.
Depending on the political climate.
They try to really understand what they
fundamentally think.
So as new issues arise,
they're responses are complete rather
than conflicted.
This is something I've really tried to
incorporate into my thinking and
something that I know many of you are
trying to do as well.
This will also be.
Candice is challenged now and I think
she's up to it,
but only she could decide that for
herself.
It blows my mind that every conversation
we have in this room seems to become
more and more relevant as time goes by.
For All I know,
we'll have Kanye in that guest seat soon
enough,
whether he is just rocket fuel to boost
ideas or is he the rocket ship that will
get us to the solutions remains to be
seen but make no mistake.
The issues around free speech,
political correctness,
and the uncomfortable truths that might
be the answers to those questions have
just been leveled up.
Are the players ready for the next
level?
We'll soon find out
joining me today as a national security
expert,
the best selling author of defeating
Jihad,
and a former.
I'll be at brief strategists to
president trump,
Dr Sebastian Gorka.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me,
David.
I'm happy to have you here.
Sara.
First off that voice,
you have a very.
Have you ever done any voice over work
at all?
Um,
it's don't tell anybody,
but it's my dream.
What I wrote,
defeating Jihad.
I asked about the audio book.
I said,
I'm going to get to do the audio book
right by publishers.
You couldn't do the prologue.
Then we'll get a pro.
I was crushed.
So the next book coming out in June.
Why we fight?
I'm sorry if you're listening to margie.
I'm doing so.
I really can't believe that.
So first off,
we have already spent a good amount of
time talking about star wars,
so very impressed.
Your Green Room and that post.
I'd never seen that in the quarry posted
before on the LP,
so I'm impressed.
That is the original 1977 poster.
I wonder,
do you think,
because we're obviously going to talk a
lot about national security and foreign
policy and all that,
do you think any of your thoughts
related to foreign policy had anything
to do with Star Wars?
Because I do think at some level some of
the way I view the world has been shaped
by some of the Lore and all the.
I'm not sure if it's causing effect but.
But absolutely in terms of good and
evil.
I mean totally.
I mean,
the first three movies are about good
versus evil before they become this
social justice warrior absurdity.
So yeah,
sure.
I mean,
but as much being the son
of people who lived on the Nazi and then
communist dictatorship that these things
kind of flow together so
or is and growing up under the child
with people who escaped from
dictatorship.
Right.
There you go.
All right,
so you are in California because you
were talking to a couple conservative
groups here in California.
People don't believe that conservative
groups could exist in California,
but I mentioned to you before we just
had governor John Casick on,
he was talking with Arnold
Schwartzenegger at some conservative
groups here in California.
So are,
it seems like something is happening in
California.
I don't live here,
but I come in and out to do these
events.
Uh,
something's happening.
So something clearly is happening.
Um,
the energy I felt,
uh,
the,
the events here is like the energy I
feel at events in Virginia,
um,
or,
or elsewhere,
like Texas.
And there's a commonality.
Whoever you speak to,
they keep mentioning the same things.
They talk about the gas tax,
they talk about sanctuary cities,
they talk about the burden on
businesses.
When you,
when you get these things repeated
enough times,
you realize something is happening in
California.
Who knows where it'll go,
but this isn't the state I used to say,
you know,
the People's republic just last forever.
I'm not so sure.
Really.
So do you think this could be something
that could happen as soon as our next,
our gubernatorial election that's coming
up now?
Or do you think this is sort of
longterm?
Maybe presidential election,
20 slash 20 or
all I'll say is the following with the
election of Donald J dot trump to
president.
The political rule book has been
shredded,
burnt,
buried under a Donald Trump jumped up
and down on it.
It's gone.
So,
so any past expectations,
any trendlines are irrelevant.
I mean I traveled with the president to.
We flew on Air Force One to Youngstown,
Ohio back in June.
And the Steel Valley,
right?
This is the heart of a blue collar
Democrat,
manual laborers.
And we,
we,
we arrived at the stadium and the
president was in the back.
I was doing selfies with the crowd,
the crowd selfie.
I've seen many crowds.
What does it cost me that they want to
sell for?
Yeah,
sure.
Why not?
Um,
so I got to engage with these people and
I realized that in this stage you move
on at 20,
25,000
people.
Everybody was either a former registered
Democrat,
their parents or grandparents were all
democrats.
And then what happens when the president
or when the first lady Melania comes out
of the stage,
it erupts.
The building erupts with chance with USA
drain the swamp.
And this is Democrat territory now,
if that can happen in young stoner,
youngstown,
Ohio,
who knows what can happen in California.
Yeah.
So I want to talk a little bit about
your history and your parents and
growing up that I just mentioned,
but as long as we're on the,
on the first part of the trump portion
of this,
let's just keep doing that.
I heard you at the turning point usa a
event in December.
Give a speech,
which I really thought was wonderful and
you described trump as the icebreaker
and what I've been saying around here is
that I view him as the bull in the China
shop.
We wanted a panther to knock over a few
things,
but we got the bowl and I think that
it's really the same analogy that we're
using there.
Um,
so can you just further on that one?
So,
um,
the United States was covered for at
least 30 years in this massive
permafrost layer of ice,
which is political correctness and it
had frozen over the media,
education,
politics,
all of it.
Uh,
to the extent that by the Obama
administration,
federal government was telling you who
could use which bathrooms.
So just insanity.
Um,
and then along comes a guy who,
the first day I met him in summer of
June 15 in his office in trump tower,
the first thing I knew about this man is
he's the Kryptonite of political
correctness.
I mean,
he couldn't care less about,
well,
the New York Times or CNN says about a
given issue.
So along comes this man,
layer of ice frozen over the country,
Fam slams into it like an ice breaker
and smashes through the ice.
So he breaks a pathway for,
for the nation to,
to open up that silane.
And,
and my argument to conservative
audiences is that this is great.
This is monumental.
It wasn't going to be the path that
could never have one.
It had to be the bull,
it had to be the icebreaker.
But if you know your physics of
icebreaking,
you can send that,
you know,
thousands of tons worth of shipping
there with its tungsten hall rides up on
the ice slices through it.
But if you don't have the flotilla
behind it,
that comes up and keeps that passageway
open,
what actually happens in real life?
You suddenly one ship in breaks apart
almost instantaneously.
The ice comes around the bow and read
knits itself right around the ship and
reseals.
So this is the moment in the
conservative movement where we have to
get serious about what does it mean to
be a conservative in the 21st century?
What's the role of government?
How does national security look?
Uh,
so on and so forth.
Donald Trump is the catalyst now we have
to do the heavy lifting of ideology and
politics and policy.
Yeah.
Do you think he will years from now when
we look back,
be anything other than the catalysts?
Like how do you,
how do you consider his ideas compared
to traditionally conservative ideas
because just in the last couple months
after signing the Omni bus thing,
you know,
right now when we're taking,
we're taping this a few days before
we're going to air it,
but there's a big mess in Syria.
We're not sure if there's going to be
more intervention or not.
He seems to be doing some things that
are probably a little more big
government than perhaps you want or,
or certainly then his base seems to
want.
So where do you think he fits actually
between catalyst and the enabler and the
flotilla?
So first things first.
I hate labels personally.
I,
I think labels is lazy thinking.
Um,
and in the case of Donald Trump,
that irrelevant and they have no
application,
uh,
credit.
Monica,
Monica Crowley,
my friend with this,
the weekend after
the election was David Horowitz is a,
was it a restoration weekend in Florida,
which was either going to be awake or
the party that was,
and Monica gave a great speech in which
he said,
look,
everybody misunderstands who this man
is.
He was never an ideological candidate
because you simply cannot put him in a
box because of what he does,
whether it's his attitude to gay
marriage,
whether it's.
It just is what it is.
Just a sort of mixture.
He was never an ideological candidate.
He was an attitudinal candidate and she
nailed it.
Now what does that mean?
Look at the last 40 years.
This guy is 71 years old.
He's not going to change.
He is who he is.
What has he done for the last 40 years
as a professional?
He's been committed to one thing,
excellence,
whether it's a golf course in Scotland,
whether it's skyscraper in New York,
it's excellence and all he's done is
he's taken that concept and tribes know,
translated it into excellence for
America once more and that doesn't fit
into neat neoliberal neo-con,
Paleo calm.
It just doesn't fit.
He's about getting stuff done and being
the best,
but so how do you link that to what the
general conservative movement is?
Now I get.
I get what you're saying about labels
and I say it all the time.
The labels now,
especially because of trump.
The labels are all the brothers at this
point,
but the thing that I'm struggling to
fully grasp about the trump thing is how
does this connect to.
You know,
when I see you right now,
you have a huge split,
right?
We've got the trump base and then you've
got the never trumpers and these people
are.
That should be kind of lining up.
They can't quite get there.
And how do you connect those things?
Like how do you connect what you're
going to connect you to?
The never.
Trump has a pathological pathological.
When Bill Crystal,
who's all obsequious and oleaginous to
me in the greenroom at Fox,
when he tweets out actually tweets out
in a choice between the deep state and
president trump,
I choose the deep state.
Yeah,
Bill,
you don't have a conservative.
You're a subversive right.
Can get out of the tent,
get out of the tenant.
So that's never going to happen.
The broader question of what does
conservative mean today?
We can't answer that because have you
seen a good article,
a really good article which understands
first principles,
founding principles about what trump ism
is or should be?
I haven't.
I've seen a lot of people who think they
know what they're talking about,
but who never met the president.
So I think with a lot of work to be
done,
but it's not going to be done by
conservative establishment individuals.
The NRO is not going to tell you who
trump is and the NRO is not going to
revitalize the conservative
establishment.
Right.
This is a new era.
It's exciting,
but we have to get to work to define
what it means to be a conservative.
So that to me is why it seems so obvious
that you're so passionate about this
that nobody else was going to do it.
And I think that's all.
So that's sorta what Monica was saying
and it's sorta what Horowitz has been
saying for a long time.
Even when he sat right there that no one
else was going to break through.
And now it's imperfect.
But
at least there's let.
Let,
let,
let me be brutally candid.
You know,
I grew up in the UK to Hungarian parents
who escaped communism.
I went through the private school system
in the UK,
stiff upper lip and all that stuff,
and the debating club.
So the precedent style is not exactly
the style used to.
I have to get used to it.
And I understand when people have
issues.
The biggest people,
the biggest thing people have issues
with on,
on the right of his tweets.
I get it.
But guess what?
Who was going to Defeat Hillary?
Wasn't Jeb Bush wasn't even sent.
It accrues.
None of them were going to the only
person who could come up through that
Miasma who could break through the ice
of political correctness walls,
this rank outsider from Manhattan.
And whether you like it or not,
he had to say for the Sophocles,
he was the necessary but not sufficient
calls of victory.
Um,
you don't have to like it,
but it had to be him.
With that start,
we tried to do marquess of queensberry
rules for 30 years.
What did it get us?
When did it get us?
Mitt Romney among guys.
Right?
So it had to be Donald Trump.
Now we have to backfill what it means.
Yeah.
And that seems to be where I think you
and so many of these other people that
are either part or formerly part of the
administration.
So you had a very brief stint at the
administration,
uh,
first of all.
And then some years from now they'll go.
My Dad,
he was there for 90 percent longer than
everybody else,
but it.
But it pretty breached in seven months.
First,
can you just tell me how you got
involved because you had only,
you just mentioned you only met him a
little bit before the election in the
first place and then sort of what
happened that had you leave because that
will really tie into the media,
which I think we're very much aligned on
what's going on with the media right
now.
So a summer of 15 I got a phone call
from a guy called Corey Lewandowski that
I'd never heard of
and he said,
uh,
candidate trump is prepping for the big
full gop presidential debate on national
security.
And you'd like to talk to you said,
sure.
So I took the plane,
flew to New York,
went to trump tower.
It was just the three of us in Donald
Trump's office and we had this
incredible blue sky discussion on
national security issues.
You name it from the civil war up to the
Middle East,
a nuclear weapons.
What kinds of topics?
How knowledgeable did he seem about
things?
Because this is one of the parts that I
think people we have no handle on,
like does he really,
really interested but not a guy that
you're going to debate what happened in
Karbala in the ninth century,
but,
but really interested in this stuff
and with opinions and,
and halfway through this discussion and
he was sitting closer to me than you are
and qualities over here and he does a
classic trumpism.
He goes,
just stops the conversation with cory.
I like this guy that's hiring and that
was it.
And he asked me to help write.
It wasn't part of the campaign,
but I became an advisor,
wrote policy papers that he used in the
briefings and we stayed in touch but I
never joined the campaign.
And then as things progressed and he
know the field whittled down to what it
did,
I kept meeting General Flynn at events.
I was a participant was just in the
crowd.
I kept bumping into General Flynn and
I'd known him from when he was directed
to dia and eventually we just.
He pulled me in and by October,
the month before the election,
I don't know if you're familiar with the
system in the presidential election,
the last two runners get a support from
the federal government before the
election and they get offices near the
White House to create transition teams
to prep.
And so hillary got one story and,
and the president got another story of
this building and I was pulled into the
pet.
Hilarious.
It's in the same building.
Oh yeah.
And you see if you talk in the elevator.
Right.
So,
uh,
so I got pulled in and asked to work on
the National Security Council Transition
Team for General Flynn and my wife who
has a background in the issues,
was pulled into work on the dhs q and a.
So I became part of the official
transition team.
And up until the very last moment,
the week before maybe the week of the
inauguration,
I was going to be doing counterterrorism
staff or General Flynn and the NSC.
And then Steve Bannon,
who knows me,
reaches out at the last minute.
So new,
they're going to come and work for me.
And the office of the chief strategist,
a strategist to the president.
And that's how,
you know,
at uh,
12.
Oh,
one on January the 20th I became a
deputy assistant to the president.
Yeah.
So the second that happened,
basically the media just went bananas.
And I knew,
I mean every store I mentioned to you
that right now the act where they went
bananas.
Was it even before that?
No,
no,
no.
It's very interesting.
They didn't,
they didn't go bananas until the travel
band dropped.
And I realized things were not going
well in terms of communicating the
travel ban.
So I said to Steve and I said to Sean
guys,
I've done a bit of media in the past.
I can be the face of this stuff if you
want.
I mean we've got the NSC communications
team,
but I'm prepared to go on CNN and debate
these guys.
And so they threw me into the,
the,
you know,
the fire.
And I loved it.
And the left went nuts.
They just absolutely went insane.
And it was once I was vehemently
representing the president on television
that out came the hit pieces.
And the lights.
Yeah.
So let's talk about that a little bit
because I see this happening to almost
everyone that I have any degree of
respect for.
I see it,
I see it.
It's coming.
It's coming to me now too.
I mean,
I see this to almost anyone that I think
is trying to be honest.
The endless effects.
I mean,
you know,
there were just endless slew of things
that you're an anti Semite and all of
this craziness.
I mean at the turning point event that I
saw you speak at,
you gave one of the strongest defenses
of Israel that I've ever heard,
but they almost take everything and do
the complete reverse of that.
What do you make of that tactic
specifically where it's literally the
reverse of what the truth is.
It's not just like we're going to take a
line and make it seem a little
different.
We're do something that's absolutely.
You've got a big viewership.
I know your why.
I'm no longer a progressive thing.
Has got millions of views now.
And I'll,
I'll open up a little bit the spot size
of your audience.
Um,
I have a reputation for being a scary
dude and being a hot ass,
that's fine,
but after the seven months that I went
through and my family went through,
every time,
every few weeks,
I have the same emotional response and
it probably surprises your others as a
human being.
I want to try and understand how another
human being who's never met me,
who knows nothing about me or what my
family has been through,
can write what they wrote about me will
say what they say about me.
It leaves me speechless that you can
have such venomous hatred for somebody
and pedal so egregious sets of lies.
And you not only call yourself a
journalist,
but you actually think you're a human
being.
Um,
I was attacked and that's fine because
I'm a politically commissioned officer
of the president.
I'm a proxy.
I was approximate for Steve as a proxy
for the president.
I understand that.
That's okay,
but hey,
why don't we debate the policies they
never wanted,
never wanted to debate the policies was
ad hominem attacks and lives.
And secondly,
it's okay to attack me,
but guess what?
It's not a kate attack,
my wife.
It's not okay to attack my dead mother's
reputation and it's not okay to attack
my teenage high school age son either
these people are reprehensible and
they're out of control,
David.
And then not learning the doubling down.
So that's the part that I'm concerned
about right now that it seat.
People always asked me.
I did an event in Irvine last night and,
and the question I'm getting more and
more now is,
is this thing turning around now?
I sense my sense is that there is
something brewing against it.
There's something brewing finally,
and I think any of us in this space or a
little piece of it,
but to me it's going to get a lot worse
before it gets better and that that's
what I'm concerned about.
Uh,
you're already.
So I suspect
you,
under what conditions does something
like that change.
If we rule out violence,
right?
We don't want to have violence.
Okay.
We've,
you know,
the,
the worst war we ever had was all civil
war.
Okay?
Six hundred thousand Americans killed.
Even though they're subtly condoning
violence,
CEO of twitter is condoning it.
Um,
so let's,
let's,
let's pray to the good Lord that that's
not where we're going.
What's the other option?
What's the other scenario that they look
in the mirror and they stopped,
but one would thing they reward each
other for the lies.
I mean,
look at Time Magazine's latest issue.
It's just a for Rango of lines.
It's all opinion pieces,
not journalism.
When they look at the people who they
celebrate at their get togethers,
they're not journalists.
I mean there's maybe six journalists
left in this country that are actually
doing investigative research like Sarah
Carter,
right?
Like Molly Hemingway.
When are they going to be recognized by
the Washington press corps?
Never,
never,
because they don't comport with the
narrative that we're Nazis.
And the president is a dictator.
This is a man whose grandchildren are
orthodox Jews.
Can you wrap your heads around it?
New York Times,
CNN,
Huffington Post,
buzzfeed.
You'll reprehensible for calling this
administration what you call it.
I know that he doesn't,
not that he doesn't have a racist bone
in his body.
He doesn't have a racist molecule in his
body.
The stunning thing,
and this is,
this is what,
why it was such an honor to work for
him.
The stunning thing about Donald trump
is,
and look,
I got a Bible in my pocket.
I can swear on it.
I'll swear on this Bible.
This man wants only two things.
We're all Americans.
He wants you and your family to be safe
and he wants you to prosper,
which is what all American president
should want,
but you know it's starting,
David.
He wants that for you.
Whether or not you voted for him or not,
he doesn't care whether you voted for
Hillary.
He doesn't care whether you want to burn
it all and he doesn't care whether you
stayed at home and ate doritos.
If you're an American living here
legally,
he wants you to be safe from harm,
from gangs,
from terrorism,
and he wants you to prosper like he has
prospered.
And the left.
This is the answer to your question.
The left will never ever believed that.
Although it is true and I tested it.
So when they put you out there and as
you said you.
No,
no,
no.
That,
that,
that's what it's all about,
right.
That's what it's all about.
What you just said there,
when they put you out there and as you
said,
you willfully went out to,
to go for the,
for the ban the Muslim ban.
I when,
uh,
when we talked about it on our tour,
but I'm glad for it to their narrative.
Okay.
So we talked about it a bunch of the
show.
I
did a bunch of videos.
I tried to be very fair.
I have Muslim friends,
I've had Muslims on the show and ex
Muslims and I've had people that are
critical of religion and people that are
religious in the whole freaking thing.
Look,
most of the countries,
the most of the most populous countries
of Muslim people were not included on
the band.
The original list,
the original list was Oklahoma by the
Obama administration.
All that.
So I tried to talk about it as fairly as
possible,
but it seems to be one of those issues.
And then I think this will sort of lead
us a little bit into your book as well,
talking about radical Islam and trying
to make the distinction between Islam as
a set of ideas versus Muslims as people.
And of course you shouldn't be prejudice
and all of that.
This seems to be basically the stickiest
thing that we have going right now,
right?
Like the quicksand to even talk about
it.
Okay.
Uh,
you mean the threat,
the threat of jihadism?
Well,
just trying to kind of things that are
so well the quicksand of trying to make
the distinction of we have to be able to
talk about ideas and what we have to
fight for good ideas and against bad
ideas,
but at the same time make sure that
we're not being prejudice towards people
and making sure that America remains the
open plurals,
pluralistic society that it is.
Look at the argument in,
in my book,
different jihad is a very simple one.
Um,
we live in the only country ever created
on the principle of individual freedom
and liberties and granted to us,
not by the government,
but by our creative because we are made
in his image,
not the founding fathers said you are,
you have dignity because you all made in
the image of the creator,
not because Washington says you have
dignity.
And that concept of the individual's
dignity and the freedom that it provides
is antithetical to the spectrum of
politics that says manage perfectible
and perfection can be created in real.
My first degree was philosophy and
theology.
And I study,
uh,
this event here in California.
All politics can be,
can be all ideological differences can
be summarized in just two camps.
It doesn't matter which country you're
in or what era,
two camps,
those that believe truth is objective
and not manmade.
And those who say no man can define
truth and perfection can be created here
on earth.
This statement that man defines truth
leads to the gas chambers and to the
gulags.
Okay?
Now,
social justice warriors don't realize
that they're walking down the same path,
but it's the same concept to say,
I'm going to perfect the world and there
will be justice and equality.
No,
you won't.
If we are free,
there will never be justice for all and
equality for all,
as long as we are free because evil is
real.
Evil exists.
Man is fallen and jihadism is just the
latest version.
Like my book is a very simple argument.
There is a connective tissue between al
Qaeda and Isis and the Nazis of the
Third Reich and the comments of the
Soviet Union.
Yes,
they watch different things on worship
and Erin Rice when we should work in
class,
the other worship,
that version of Islam,
but guess what?
The connective tissues,
they're all totalitarians and if you
disagree with them,
guess what?
You're going to be enslaved or murdered.
End of story and if you.
If you deny that reality,
I've trained,
I don't know,
six,
$7,000
federal officers.
I've trained more than that in the
military.
When the military professional and FBI
agent understands that his government is
telling him what he can or cannot say
about the threat group is supposed to be
protecting us from then we have problems
when President Obama says in a 2011
writes a memo to the chairman of the
joint chiefs and the then attorney
general all counter terrorism training
of FBI agents and the US military must
not mention Islam and especially must
not mention the word Jihad.
Well,
that's like saying we're about to storm
the Normandy beaches and guys make sure
you're [inaudible] one's loaded and your
boots are tied up,
but whatever you do,
don't mention the word Nazi because you
could offend a German.
It's a bad snl skit,
David.
It's insanity and the fact that we
weren't allowed to talk about it
truthfully,
that gets people killed.
Political correctness
eventually can lead to good people
dying,
so that also explains why there's such
craziness in Europe right now.
Right?
I mean,
we're going to see.
It seems to me that we're going to
consistently see the rise of right or
far right parties,
but it really is just the symptom of not
being able to talk about these issues.
Honestly.
Let's differentiate between the rise of
two different things.
Okay.
So,
um,
we've just had an election in Hungary.
We've seen the elections in Italy and
elsewhere and we've seen brexit.
Let's don't conflate two issues.
There's the rise of very disturbing,
uh,
groups like your back in Hungary that
are really crypto nationalists and,
and feed off a,
a long seated antisemitic kind of era
dentist,
a sentiment in the country.
So these are the true
sort of.
They're not all white nationalists,
but the true sort of,
they want ethno state and they want,
right?
Well,
it's complicated because as history that
has tree and on this side,
but that big.
Yeah,
little nuggets.
Okay.
Then that you mustn't conflate that with
the trump phenomena and things like
brexit,
original,
a causation,
and I don't even use the word populism.
I reject the word populism,
unless your definition is part of
populism is a,
those kinds of politics that the elite
disagrees with.
Good.
Definitely.
I'm pretty sure that's not the standard
for me.
This isn't populism that trump winning
or brexit happening.
This is a reassertion of democracy.
I mean why?
Why did trump occur?
Because people on the left and the right
looked at DC and said,
you know,
I don't know the difference between
Sunni and Shia,
but guess what?
It's broken.
I don't know what a federal
budget should look like,
but we were spending like drunken
sailors,
so it's the reassertion of accountable
politics,
vice faceless bureaucracy or uni party
swamp to others,
whether they're in DC or whether they're
in Brussels.
So for me it should be.
We should welcome it with open arms.
This is a reassertion of accountable
government,
but for the left that wants uniformity
of thought and bigger government.
It's fascism.
So how does the,
how do then does the right.
How do you police that?
I know that you don't like that idea of
policing and government coming in fixing
it,
but how do you make sure that the part
that you're worried about doesn't lead
to the good part?
Because I think from the way,
at least from the way I see it,
the left is always lead now by its worst
parts,
so for them,
that's why they purge everybody.
The video that you mentioned that I did,
I'm praying for you.
That's what I talked about.
I mean,
anyone that steps out of group think you
get purged and that's why I think
there's such a movement towards
libertarianism or classical liberalism
or whatever you wanna call it,
so I see what the left's doing on that.
How do you make sure that doesn't happen
on the right where the far right that
you were worried about,
you think it's fair estimation to call
it fire,
right?
Yeah.
I don't even like the alt right.
I think it's bogus.
I think those are just.
That's a new label for nationalist or or
or,
or incidental bigots.
All right.
That's a reader that re wrapping
themselves to be solid.
Faith will be fit for polite company.
Well,
I hate to tell you,
I hate to tell you on your wikipedia
page,
it calls you all right.
Of course.
Right.
And offset the page.
That doesn't allow the subject to
correct when I try and correct the lies.
It's frozen.
Interesting.
Wikipedia you.
I told you right before we started,
but your wikipedia out of all of the
ones that.
Because I usually just glance there,
not for fact,
but just to get a sense of what's going
on.
Yours is such a mess.
It's.
I've tried.
I've tried to correct the friends who
have tried to correct it.
Then they froze it and then forget about
it.
Yeah.
So what do you do though to make sure
that those two songs don't come?
We need to spine.
So those of us that have a podium,
those that are out there,
those that wish to see the principles we
believe in in terms of the founding come
back and be celebrated in this country.
We have to call them out like we don't
believe that you use legislation.
I mean hate speech.
Give me a break.
I mean,
either you're inciting violence,
so you will not,
either you're committing a crime or
you're not.
We don't need extra labels and we don't.
It's censorship.
Call them out for what they need.
People on the right hand side.
You know what?
He's a racist.
That.
All right.
Think that's just bigotry.
That's just the KKK wrapped up in a new
bow.
It's up to us.
Do you think that's happening?
That's not gonna do it,
right?
They're going to use it.
You want to use those people to silence
the majority.
Do you think that went not enough?
Not Enough,
but by far,
um,
we have um,
begun,
but there's a lot of work to do.
Yeah.
Does everything that's happening in
Europe right now and there's definitely
a distinction to be made between what's
happening in eastern Europe.
Western Europe
and Eastern Europe I think is dealing
with some of their existential crisis.
He's a little bit better perhaps because
western Europe still a little behind on
the political correctness stuff that
you're talking about.
Does everything that's happening in
Europe right now?
Does it all come down to immigration,
do you think?
No,
no,
no.
Uh,
immigration,
uh,
was the blue touch paper on the
firework?
No,
it's,
it's the death of representative
democracy.
I mean,
I watched this because I grew up in the
UK under Margaret Thatcher.
For me,
Maggie,
the Gipper blessed St John Paul the
second.
These were my heroes.
I remember riding to school on the bus
in the morning in west London and the
bus driver would be Jamaican.
I'd be with my Indian or Pakistani
school body I with,
with this Polish guy next to me.
I mean it's super hydrogenous part of
London and as far as far as I was
concerned,
these are all Brits.
The guy must've might've had the
thickest Jamaican accent possible.
My,
my,
my friend Martin's mom cooked the best
Indian cars,
but guess what?
We're all British.
Yeah,
that's gone.
You know,
when Tony Black came in,
when Clinton came in,
this idea that,
you know,
the West is guilty and words like
British,
a pejorative to your wealth or whatever
that was the death of these countries.
I mean,
why do you think I'm in America?
I'm a proud American citizen now because
they lost the plot.
The things that the Gi guys that fought
for that,
the Tommy's fought for make safe spaces,
really got 19 year olds that are being
blown up over Berlin and bomber planes
and you want a safe space.
This is in a space of 70 years.
I mean,
what's going on in London right now?
Here's the line of Churchill.
Yeah,
it's shocking.
So I saw,
I'm sure you saw this,
but just in the last couple of weeks
they said London's crime.
Violent crime has now surpassed New York
cities for the first time in history.
And then Cindy Kahn,
who's the mayor,
a statement saying,
you can't carry knives.
I mean,
first off,
people are walking out with Swiss army
knives,
a woman that might want to protect
herself.
My one have a knife in her pocket.
I mean it.
It seems like a mass mental disorder to
me,
but that's what happens.
That is the natural progression when you
deny objective truth.
If everything is plastic,
then you will get wrapped around your
own act solely in absurdities and for
for mayor of one of the most powerful
cities in the world of financial centers
to say no one should ever have a knife
on them and nobody needs a knife.
So every plumber,
every tradesman,
every person working at the fish market
is suddenly out of a job.
So conduit,
insane.
So what does your Britain or Europe in a
wider sense have to do to reverse the
tide on
some of this stuff?
I mean,
Nigel Farrage,
I dunno.
I mean it's lucky that the saying and
crops up in every nation and every
country deserves the politicians.
They elect.
Don't bitch and Moan.
Get up the street where I live outside
DC.
I mean you're the conservatives who's so
fed up and they're constantly posting
stuff on facebook.
What have you done to do something about
it?
Have you gone out with leaflets?
Have you given more than $5 to a local
candidate?
Have you given up and surrender?
I see this all the time that people who
say,
well,
greatest nation on earth,
and then they said,
well,
you know,
we're going purple and bureaucrats moved
in and what are you going to do?
What are you going to do?
Would you have said that in 17,
76,
the founding fathers have said,
what are you going to do?
No.
Is this just a symptom of the success of
the West that we've just become so
successful that you're right.
We kind of sit there and we sit on
twitter and we complain all day,
but we're all talking.
We're not doing anything like it's all
talk.
It's not do a.
it's much more than that.
It's deep.
I mean,
I.
I went to the Jesuits.
I studied philosophy under them.
It was painful,
but I will,
I won't regret a minute of it.
Identity is a function of history and
culture and values and if,
if you don't study Western civilization
and your schools colleges,
this is what happens.
If you don't understand why people have
dignity,
just that they do.
Oh,
unless that conservatives,
right.
This is where you arrive at and and you
know who's responsible for this.
I don't play in the Left,
David.
This is not the.
This is not the left's culpability.
It's ours.
It's the conservatives.
The radicals,
when they saw Paris and fire in 1968,
believed that they could do the segment
America,
that we could have a left wing
revolution.
This is what your students were
democratic society believed,
and when Bernadine,
dohrn and bill as took over the SDS and
try to execute the Chicago days of rage.
What happened?
Because Americans are not rabble rousing
a leftists.
It died.
It was a damp squib article there.
Maoist revolution.
The,
the.
What was it?
The prairie fire manifesto died
instantly.
So what did they decide?
They'd read that Trotsky.
They'd read their lending.
They even knew.
Hitler said,
give me that children and our own their
future.
So these people actually became tenured
professors in Chicago.
They became high school teachers.
And what did we do on the right?
We let them.
People who are avowedly believe America
is evil.
We're allowed to influence our education
system to the point at which they pretty
much owned it.
But with exceptional,
your hillsdale and grove city,
they own the education
system.
And what was our response?
Homeschooling.
Great.
I love the movement,
but you're not going to save,
but that ain't,
that ain't enough.
Yeah.
So,
um,
it's gonna be a hard slog.
It's going to be 20,
30 years of saying guys,
America means this and it's nothing to
do with your skin color.
It's nothing to do with your sexual
preference,
your social class,
your gender.
America is eternal values and that's,
that's gonna be a lot of work.
Alright.
So I want to shift a little bit to
foreign policy because I think that sort
of a,
one of your,
one of your.
Would you say that's one of your main
strengths?
So my,
my,
my claim to fame is counter terrorism
and stuff like this.
But,
but really deep down I'm a strategy
wank.
Grand Strategy is my thing.
Okay.
So we'll talk.
We'll talk in the language and strategy
then.
So as we're taping this right now,
I mentioned earlier,
it's gonna,
it's gonna sit on the shelf for a couple
of days,
so I don't want to get too lost in
anything that happened today,
but at the moment it's a little upside
down in Syria.
We know there might've been strikes
already from when we're taping this.
A hungry just had elections in your
wikipedia that I referenced earlier.
It says you worked for the guy who just
won you.
Apparently you never worked for him.
He told his potty.
I wasn't victim to Audubon's advising,
which is what it says on Wikipedia at
least.
Um,
what,
what's your general thoughts on foreign
policy strategy?
Like what is a sensible policy and
Eddie's trump applying that view?
Uh,
first things first.
the great irony of all nation is that we
are the most powerful nation in the
world has ever seen.
And until recently we have been the
dumbest and most a strategic.
I mean we haven't done,
we haven't thought or acted
strategically since about 1989.
November the ninth when the Berlin Wall
fell.
And,
and this is,
you know,
how have we acted?
What,
what would you say that since then,
it's just nineties was just this kind of
confused.
What is national security about lurching
for the snooze button,
just who are the threats is that China
is a weapons of mass destruction and say
you just love it.
It was just a mess.
And then we had 2001 and nine slash 11
and we had just as neo-con disasters,
it's not an accident.
These guys were former trotskyites
because they're so naive the way they
look at the world that we're going to
create democracy at the end of a gun
barrel in a country with 36 languages
that defeated Alexander the Great and
the British empire and the Soviets.
You couldn't be stupid or if you tried.
So,
you know,
we,
we've done some very,
very foolish things because we haven't
stuck to the basics.
Strategy at the end of the day is about
one thing.
It's about prioritization based upon
interests.
But you've got to say some things are
more important than others.
And guess what?
Some countries are more important than
others.
And in a postmodern secular world,
you'll not allowed or no countries,
oh,
Vanuatu is as
important as Turkey wrong.
It's not that I love the people that a
while too,
but no,
it's not a geo strategic import to the,
to the country of America.
So number one,
we have to prioritize and I think this
administration,
I dock my cap to Nadia shadow a HR
mcmasters deputy.
She held the pen in the meetings that I
was in on the new national security
strategy of America.
And I tell you David,
it is the first document of that name in
steady is that deserves the name
national security strategy.
Every administration has them.
This is the first one that says,
this is what we stand for.
These are our values,
these are our friends,
these are our enemies and this is what
we're going to prioritize.
Prior to that,
it was laundry lists of,
well we're going to have to front walls,
we're going to save the whales and you
know know.
So you have to prioritize.
And finally this administration is about
America first.
We are not isolationists,
nor are we interventionists.
This is really annoys me that if you're
a conservative for 20 years you were
given two options,
button a invade other people's countries
and occupy them button.
Be be a Randy Sta and close the curtains
on the Pacific and the Atlantic and say,
we don't care about anybody else.
Well guess what is the most powerful
nation in the world?
There is a large pallet of options.
It's got to be something in the middle
there.
Yeah,
so it's about being smart.
It's about our interests and it.
To summarize the president's approach,
this isn't official,
but I like it.
We have numerous former generals and
active generals from the Marine Corps at
the highest level of administration
showed the joint chiefs,
Chief of staff,
secretary defense.
And the interesting thing is they all
come from the same Marine Corps
division,
not just the Marine Corps,
the same division.
And that division has a motto,
no better friend,
no worse enemy.
That's America first.
So when you see someone like John Bolton
a now part of the cabinet,
and if you were to look on,
you know,
not that you can get truth out of
twitter,
but the day it was happening,
you know,
everybody's saying this is going to
start world war three and just the
general hysterics.
And now John Bolton is definitely
suspect more of a neocon than you're
comfortable with it.
Is that.
I don't think it's fair to Chordoma
Naoko.
I don't,
I don't think he's ideologically driven.
If you watch the videos that he know
recording of his speech is 20 years ago,
he was certainly very much like trump.
We're America and we have interests.
You want to work with us,
fight.
If you don't,
there's a problem.
So,
um,
and I think it's very telling that
within 40 minutes of the president's
tweet about John Coming on board,
um,
massive bulk and gave an interview on
Fox and they asked him about what are
you going to be like as a national
security advisor?
And he gave a very interesting onset.
He could've Dean Acheson and you know,
the,
the doyen of foreign policy in America,
and uh,
I don't know if this is true story,
but John said the natural one was once
asked,
how do you have such a good relationship
with the president in serve
Indian actress and said,
well,
it's very easy.
We may disagree on policy issues,
but at the end of the day,
I never forget who was elected president
and it wasn't me.
That's a John Bolton two point.
Oh,
he understands that unlike his
predecessor hr mcmaster,
he's not there to lecture the president
or forced his version of what you should
do onto the commodity and chief.
He's at to be an honest broker and
provide a palate of options because
guess who gets to decide the person who
was elected president.
So I'm very excited about John and I,
I'm,
I'm as excited about Mike pompeo coming
from the CIA to the State Department
that we are in.
Very good hands,
David.
So how do you make sure,
if it's between the pure isolationists
and,
and the neocons or something,
something like the nation builder,
something like that.
How do you make sure that not everything
that you do outside of our borders
becomes something much bigger?
I mean,
look,
we're still at war in Afghanistan.
I don't think anyone knows why.
I mean,
can you,
can you tell me why we're at war in
Afghanistan?
Can anyone tell me why we went,
why we went to Afghanistan in October
of,
uh,
one is the only reason we should be that
today.
Nothing's changed.
Okay.
The idea that goes go to school.
I love it.
I get it that people can listen to music
freely and the Taliban won't execute
you.
My parents lived on the communism.
My father suffered under fascism.
He protected his fellow Jewish
classmates during the occupation of
Budapest.
I get it.
I don't like those kinds of systems,
but there's only one reason why they
were there to make sure that that piece
of land that would never ever again be
used to execute mass casualty attacks in
Manhattan,
in Washington or in a field in
Pennsylvania.
End of story.
It's not about building a ring road
around Kabul.
The not even the Soviets could finish.
It's not about building hospitals.
I'm sorry you never make the ideal,
the enemy of the good.
What the president does is he looks at
things as questions of possibility.
You cannot be a massively successful
realtor in the toughest market in the
world,
which is New York real estate.
If you have a filter that distorts
reality,
I mean either this square footage is
worth x or it's not worth x according to
the market and that's how he approaches
these issues.
So Afghanistan is only important to make
sure that bad guys don't use it again to
kill Americans in America.
So.
So you would say,
or at least if you were,
if you had to guesstimate basically what
he believes you would say that he
believes that still keeping us there at
the moment is still accomplishing.
Oh,
I don't have to get somebody tell you
that.
Yeah.
So you believe that as well because he
just seems unclear and it has nothing to
do.
He will.
He will never.
I tend to write this 71 year old man who
is now the most powerful man in the
world,
will never,
ever,
ever buy into a nation building scenario
anywhere outside of the United States.
Not happening for the next seven years.
End of story and the idea that you have
my followers on twitter,
tearing their hair out,
the boltons going to invade Syria guys,
get a grip on reality and stop talking
about crisis actors and 10 fall how to
garbage.
It's not gonna happen while the
president's the president.
Well that I tweeted something to that
effect the day of the Bolton thing
because it also reminds me that people
don't understand basic deterrence that
you have to bring in people that you
know,
talk a big game.
So that pronounced to arrange these.
Hello?
Right.
The man who was going to take us to war,
what did he do?
I think the success in North Korea today
has in large part been been a thanks to
his tweets because that's how you deal
with dictators.
You make fun of them.
They hate that.
And then you were ridiculed him.
Right?
And then you do what you scare them.
Oh,
Lo and behold,
they want to negotiate for the first
time in 65 years.
Well,
isn't that interesting?
Do you think there's any chance he would
ever give up his nukes?
About three percent because at that
point,
what leverage does he have left?
Right?
So that you still think it's worth
having the talks to figure out what we
can.
Absolutely.
Because what's happened for the last 25
years?
Escalation,
escalation,
escalation.
I mean we,
we have given into nuclear blackmail
since Bill Clinton.
Uh,
so yeah,
we have to at the end of the day,
we have to remember 1953 was not a peace
treaty in 1953 in Korea was a ceasefire
and an armistice and that,
that is actually a wall that's just
simply been frozen for 65 years.
Will be nice to have a little bit of a
peace treaty or something.
Yeah.
How much of what's happening in the
world right now?
Do you?
You must be thrilled,
I assume with everything going on at the
UN,
Nikki Haley as basically walked in there
and John Bolton two point.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
she strikes me as.
I almost wondered,
did trump really know what he was
getting with?
Ideally?
Yeah.
Did anyone know?
Anybody did?
Yeah,
we're,
we're going to do,
do you know her at all?
Where do you think that,
that kind of.
I don't know her as a friend.
Um,
she found herself.
She found herself in more power to her.
What,
what usefulness do you see in the UN at
this point?
Because it seems like truly it seems
like the most corrupt should be backward
pushed into the river.
I mean really,
I,
well the buildings basically other now
they're going to quote that and go,
you see,
he was calling for him to be knocking.
Look,
the idea was a good idea in 1945 in San
Francisco,
let's have an organization that stops us
from killing 60 million people again.
Um,
but when you look in dictatorships like
China and Russia into the Security
Council with veto power and then you
create this,
this empire of UN organizations,
I mean,
has that been a year in the last 20
years that we haven't seen a UN scandal?
Whether it's money for oil,
whether it's UN troops raping children
in Africa?
Have we seen it one year without a UN
scandal?
I don't think so.
So try and reform it.
And if you come with a question,
the validity of what it does.
I forget.
I'm not talking about,
you know,
the,
the children's rights organizations and
food,
food security.
I'm talking about its main mission which
is stability and safety.
Failed abysmally.
Yeah.
What,
what do you make of the endless
obsession with Israel that something
like 47 of the last 51 resolutions are
against Israel and usually voted on by
countries.
Sorry,
but that alone is a reason to dissolve
the UN mean what a lack of moral
compass.
What an utter bankruptcy of the morality
that there are nations in the world that
actually still have slavery going on.
Slavery where we're basic human rights
for individuals are not guaranteed based
upon sex based upon lifestyle choices.
And you're going to lambast Israel the
only democracy in the Middle East.
Yeah,
I think.
I think you nailed it.
I mean that,
that in and of itself is a reason enough
to question the future of the UN.
So is the US sort of in an odd position
where it's like if we don't do anything,
nothing can get done sort of.
And that,
that then puts us endlessly in these
quagmires or at least in these positions
where we can either watch the world burn
or get involved in things where we may
end up adding to the burning in the
first place.
Like for example,
you know,
with Russia going into Crimea,
they gave up their weapons,
right?
They gave up the weapons.
They said alright,
NATO is going to take care of us,
but what that really means is the United
States is going to take care of you.
And I'm not saying we should have gone
in and done anything there,
but that we're in this endless situation
now where it is either us there,
there is no international fighting.
Yeah,
you're super careful not to get caught
in a binary dichotomy.
You can absolutely say a world without
American leadership is a more dangerous
world because it was for the last eight
years.
Look,
I mean we had a government that actually
said we're going to lead from behind,
which is an oxymoron.
You cannot lead from behind.
We're going to have strategic patients,
which means we do nothing and allow
others to act.
What happened?
You name it from China building fate,
ministry basis on fake islands to isis,
to Russia invading.
It was just a disaster.
We back the guy,
the other guys and Rebecca.
So yeah,
to say that a world without American
leadership is,
is more dangerous,
is true,
but that doesn't mean that we have to
fix everybody's problem and that's where
smart strategy comes in where you say,
but we have a moral duty to espouse
certain values,
but that doesn't mean we are responsible
for all human beings because.
Because American revolution says the
opposite,
right?
Each nation is responsible,
the citizens are responsible if you
don't like your system,
do something about it because guess what
we did against the most powerful empire
in the world.
So,
um,
again,
it's about finding that,
that happy medium in the middle and
being smart about it.
And again,
without being callous,
being realistic,
right?
There are atrocities everywhere from
Orlando to Yugoslavia,
part American taxpayers going to pay for
fixing all of them.
Are we responsible?
Are they responsible for what's
happening in their country?
Sure are the times when we could perhaps
help them,
but it's a balance to balance.
All right,
so let's shift back to your book
defeating Jihad.
It seems to me that the main sort of
narrative on this is not that we can
defeat it,
but we should live with it,
that there's a degree of it with which
we should just live,
which is don't carry knives in London
and it's,
you know,
we're going to put up more barricades so
the trucks can't be driven into
buildings or into shopping centers or
just down the street and killing people
that we can't really defeat this
ideology.
We just have to manage it.
Right.
I suspect you do not agree with that
premise because we've defeated
ideologies before.
You can't look.
There are idiots who run around with
swastika arm bands today.
I get it.
So Nazi-ism hasn't disappeared,
but we have made it so anathema that if
you walk down the street with a Nazi
flag,
you will be rejected by society
instantly.
The same thing with the KKK,
right?
Sadly,
not with Che Guevara was a hammer and
sickle.
Right,
right,
right.
But,
but there are ways to defeat ideologies
or to put them in a box where the La
football and everybody shuns them.
We have to do the same thing with
jihadism.
This is my argument.
This is the conclusion of the book.
We have to be as effective in dealer
gentamycin.
The message of Jeff,
because very simply put,
killing jihadis is great,
but at the end of the day,
a bodybags as a metric,
not a good metric.
It didn't work in Vietnam doesn't work
today because guess what?
If you've got a recruiting pool,
it's massive.
Not just recruit new jihadis,
so what's your victory condition?
Your victory condition is when the life
style of jihad is no longer sexy from
Brussels to San Bernardino.
How do you do that?
You make a laughingstock.
You discredit that value system.
We're not asking white skin Catholic
isn't going to do it right,
but we help.
President Sisi were helped.
King Abdullah of Jordan will help mbes
in Saudi Arabia.
I mean mbs,
historic things.
He said,
I mean massive about Israel in just the
last few weeks.
That's how we win because sooner or
later enough people say,
those guys are losers.
That's how we win,
but you only do that if you get to talk
about it.
Truthfully.
You've got to be able to talk about the
Koran or jihad means the history of the
religion because if you can't talk about
it honestly,
you're never going to treat it
accurately.
Yeah.
We're not very good at that though.
Well,
political correctness,
right?
I mean,
imagine if you're a doctor and you've
got a patient that comes in with a third
stage lymphoma,
but your hospital administrator,
because it's a scary word,
has banned the use of the word cancer.
You can't say it right.
It's just not allowed.
Yeah,
and then you have to tell the patient
what,
well,
you know,
you're dehydrated.
Go home,
drink some water,
and take some aspirin.
What happens to your patient?
And they die.
It's the same thing.
If you can't diagnose a geo strategical
issue accurately,
however much money you throw at it,
you will not solve the problem.
So are you concerned at all that just
even if it's purely because of the way
the media frames things that perhaps
trump is not the right person to lead
the fight against this,
that for whatever,
whatever he's going to say about Jihad
or a radical Islamic terrorism or the
rest,
even if he said everything the exact way
that you wanted it to be sad,
cleanly and clearly and correctly
defined all of that,
that he may not be the right messenger
on this just because of the filter it
has to get through to get to reality.
He's not the right messenger
domestically because of what political
correctness is wrought in our country,
but he is absolutely the right message.
Internationally.
Watch the video of his speech.
Don't watch him.
Watch the 53 mostly matter of heads of
state and the body language because man
did he say,
guys,
you got a problem in your most and your
society is extremely determined.
You have to deal with it.
It was tough.
A new thing that'd be all negative and
arms crossed.
They were beaming,
right?
Cc Abdullah.
We're going,
oh,
finally a guy who understands our
problem and what is giving us tough
love.
So yeah,
he,
he is absolutely the right guy to fix
this internationally,
which is where it needs to be fixed
domestically.
Now the political correctness thing is
going to get in the way.
The media insanity.
So do you think he has more support from
foreign heads of state and then we'll
have a sense.
I mean even at the Ga there was a
feeling of like that actually these guys
kinda liked him or I can tell you.
Yeah,
I told people before the inauguration,
you have no idea.
Even if you voted for him,
you have no idea how successful he will
be internationally because he's a
straight shooter because he's an Alpha
dog.
And guess what?
In a lot of places outside of Berkeley
they like have that right?
Because they know what you're talking
about.
They don't have to walk on eggshells.
They understand your direction.
So yeah,
internationally are prestige as a nation
has skyrocketed in,
you know,
outside of the European Union and maybe
certain century pin countries exempted.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Uh,
I know we could do a whole
other show on this,
but,
but very quickly just on Russia
collusion,
as someone that has been around the
administration,
you've mentioned some of these people
already,
flint,
you know,
down the road.
Well,
what,
what can you tell me about that and is
there anything that people should be
worried about or do you think this is
all going to actually point just back to
the Democrats,
which every time it seems,
every time it seems to point to trump,
you go a little bit further and then
going,
oh,
well,
wait a minute.
That was actually the Democrats do.
My good friend has a,
the best morning show in DC.
Uh,
I'm Chris plot.
The radio host is actually a national
syndicated and I have to credit him with
this.
He says it's the last scene from the
hunt for Red October when the bad
captain Tupolev launches the torpedoes
against Sean connery on the radio
October.
And it takes the fuses off and then what
happens?
Remember his ex says,
your thing comes back and syncs them.
This is the most hilarious boomerang in
history,
right?
I'll tell you what the president told me
in the Oval Office,
it's just the two of us.
It was very frustrated one day I think
maybe dad had just testified or given
his speech,
his little press conference,
and he said they will not find anything
because there is nothing and you know
what?
I take that to the bank.
There is no Russia collusion.
How could there be off for the last 15
months from arming the Ukrainians to the
xl pipeline to Anwar to finally after 30
years,
the first president to ever get NATO to
finally stump up the two percent of GDP
that they promised they'd spend on
defense to our own military expenditure
increases.
Every significant policy decision this
president has taken with regards to
Russia has been bad for that former KGB
colonel,
so the idea that we're colluding,
you have to be on drugs or be so
ideologically blind to believe that,
well then what do we do with this?
This layer,
you know,
whatever that you.
You've referenced deep state before,
whatever.
Yeah.
What?
What do we do with this thing?
Do we have an ongoing investigation?
To me,
the Mueller investigation,
which seems odd to me,
is that I don't know what the actual.
I don't know that they ever laid out
what their mission is other than to find
what was the crime,
right and that illusion to commit to
collusion to conspire in a crime.
Okay,
but what's the crime?
Because if it's Russia misrepresenting
itself or perverting the truth on
facebook,
well then Zuckerberg should be charged
then.
Then you know Anderson Cooper should be
in the dark.
What are the charges that have been
brought outrageously ridiculous or lying
to federal investigators?
You?
You would probably be able to be caught
in a perjury trap today.
Okay,
because not everybody remembers what
they did and how they did it.
Poetry traps.
What you said to somebody Irri
irrespective of Russia.
That's not donald trump's problem.
Why a fraud?
Eight years ago when manafort worked for
the Ukrainian president,
what's that going to do with Russian
collusion?
Nothing.
My worry is that Mueller is not a good
actor.
If you look at who is hired,
it's clear that there's massive bias and
this report is writing for Congress is
simply going to be a political weapon in
the elections and and that's not how
justice is served.
That's the rule of law.
That's a law enforcement official
getting involved in politics.
So that's what I'm concerned about.
Also,
whether,
whether you think something for the
people that are watching this,
the thing something happened or didn't
happen,
what I'm more concerned about is that
we're entering this new phase where
whether it's trump that's president or
it's a Democrat that's president or it's
a different republican or whatever,
that we're just going to endlessly also
have this layer that all it does is
investigate itself.
Waste money,
you know,
just constantly just be keeping us all
in this state where we never know what's
real.
Because if you listen to half of the
pundits on television,
I mean their implication is that Russia
has installed our president,
in which case that's probably the single
biggest active board and the history of
the world and what are you actually
saying?
Do we take trump out?
And then do you take out pence and now
should Paul,
right?
I mean if you take it to its logical
conclusion or do we have Paul Ryan as
president then and right where are you
really taking this?
And that's what I'm worried about is
that we're just going to end up in this
constant state where yes,
we'll have a democrat and a Republican
or whatever,
but we'll really be caught in just con.
All government can do is investigate
itself be more than anything else.
I see myself as an optimist,
but you're giving me a real challenge
with that last one.
I see myself as an optimist too,
but I think I'm a realist.
So for months and months and months or
refused to use the phrase deep state,
I really thought that was a tinfoil hat.
He kind of thing.
One of the record,
I don't even know that I've even said it
once on this show.
It sort of pops up and answers.
Uh,
I
use it now because I've seen it.
I've seen it inside the administration.
When you go to enough National Security
Council meetings that are classified,
that is the,
the,
the pinnacle of policymaking in America
outside of the Oval Office,
and this is where policy's made.
Everybody's in the room from the NSC.
Then you've got the outstations on
secure vtc from Dia,
a chair of the joint chiefs,
CIA state,
you name it,
right,
and you sit there as a new deployment of
political and you listen for two hours
on a big issue,
isis,
Russia,
whatever it is,
and not one participant mentions the
name of the president or what he said
yesterday in Warsaw or what his
objective is,
given that specific issue and you see
this happen again and again and again,
and you're the guy at the end of the
conversation with the funny accent.
He says,
excuse me,
ladies and gentlemen,
you do
know what the president said about x
yesterday.
Can we actually do that?
The deep state is real.
When you've got gas fifteens and scs is
saying,
well,
I've been here for 20 years.
I know this guy is going to be here for
four.
I know better.
That's bad for democracy.
So it'll be clear that you don't think
it's some sort of massive underground
conspiracy.
You think it's just the apparatus,
the,
it's just the old Washington apparatus
so that I don't think you know,
these people who think Obama sitting in
a cave somewhere with a joystick,
he's lazy.
He'd never be a Muslim was I'll specter,
not blofeld but,
but no,
there's a culture in government that's
antithetical to an undermining,
undermining the president on a daily
basis.
But,
but there is,
there is concerted effort in the media.
Oh my gosh.
I mean,
Ben Rhodes brags about Ai.
That guy's unbelievable.
What he says.
My bodies,
the left wing journalists are morons and
they're my echo chamber.
He,
he built this machine that was,
was this incestuous connection between
people in the West Wing,
people in the think tank community and
their buddies in the media.
I mean,
look at the attack pieces on anybody.
Me or whatever.
It's very interesting to.
Somebody should do a case study.
A journalism school,
one attack piece will drop at 7:00
AM by 2:00
in the afternoon,
30 have been written.
We're just simply cut and paste.
But if you don't know that,
it looks as,
oh my gosh,
gawkers a fascist.
No,
it's one guy's article.
It was written because Ben Rhodes told
them to ride it.
That comes and multiplies on the right.
How do we react?
Well,
I got my ipad international review.
This one right there.
There's a Gulf in terms of managing
narrative.
The left built,
built a whole ecosystem and we're still
in the 19 eighties,
you know?
Oh,
we'll take out a full page ad in the
Washington.
Well that's why when discussing,
right?
Yeah.
I think it's so important to not odd.
I think most people,
especially just because of the way
social media works,
they immediately go to the full on
conspiracy of Obama with the joystick or
just some other,
you know,
the globalist thing and this whole,
to me it's like they're there.
What you just described seems more
realistic to me that there's an
apparatus there that then is still
connected to the media that seems we
can,
we can discuss that in a sensible way
with one audition.
And,
and I appreciate this,
not having been,
you know,
in the target has the crosshairs for so
long,
they have an advantage because our site
is predicated on what David,
the individual manifest destiny,
the rugged individualism.
We believe in individual,
the left by definition,
as a collective entity.
There are elements of the Borg in the
left and it is a truly is a collective,
collective mob mentality.
A friend of mine on Raphael Watching,
I mean,
thank you.
[inaudible] is smoke.
What,
when,
when one guy goes off the goal Golkar or
Bannon or whoever,
the president that has this massive
collective pylon sort of conspiracy,
but it,
but it's a,
they're all on the same hymn sheet.
They don't need direction,
but they say,
Oh yeah,
let's go off to him.
Which,
which puts us on the right at a
disadvantage.
Yeah.
So this is just sort of an emerging
group thing.
It's a cultural thing.
Yeah.
Wow.
We could do.
We're,
we're going to do this again.
I hope so.
This is so much fun.
Yeah.
This was an absolute pleasure for more
on Dr Gorka can.
I feel like I have to say,
I know well it I would if I'm a pro when
I'm doing that later,
have clients who have asked you,
but I feel like Dr Gorka.
I mean you should be a star wars
character.
It's all in there for more on Sebastian,
follow him on twitter.
It's at Seb Gorka.